>> TONIGHT, YOU DETAILS
INCOMING CONGRESSMAN GEORGE
SANTOS'S CAMPAIGN FINANCES.
RECORDS THAT HIS CAMPAIGN FILED
WITH THE FCC SHOWED THAT 37
EXPENSES THAT WERE JUST ONE
PENNY BELOW THE THRESHOLD TO
KEEP RECEIPTS, $199.99.
THE FILING ALSO SEVERAL UNUSUAL
EXPENSES INCLUDING EXORBITANT
AMOUNT SPENT ON AIR TRAVEL AND
HOTELS AND MORE THAN $10,000 ON
WHAT ARE LISTED AS RENT
PAYMENTS TO THE COMPANY,
CLEANER 1 TO 3.
THE COMPANY'S ADDRESS IS HOUSE
ON LONG ISLAND OR HIS DISTRICT
IS LOCATED.
SANTOS IS ALSO FACING MORE
TROUBLE TONIGHT OVER HIS
RAMPANT LIES, SEVERAL OF HIS
CAMPAIGN DONORS TOLD ME IN MY
PRODUCER ALI GORDON THAT THEY
FEEL BETRAYED, BUT IT'S NOT
JUST HIS DONORS, VOTERS IN HIS
DISTRICT ARE ALSO OUTRAGED,
SOME WANT HIM TO RESIGN.
CNN'S EVA MCKEND AS THE STORY.
>> I FEEL COMPLETELY BETRAYED.
>> IN GEORGE SANTOS IS LONG
ISLAND DISTRICT, THE OUTRAGE IS
PALPABLE.
>> GEORGE SANTOS IS A FRAUD, I
NO LONGER SUPPORT HIM.
>> DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
ANGRY IN THE WAKE OF REVELATION
SANTOS LIED EXTENSIVELY ABOUT
HIS PERSONAL BACKGROUND AND
CREDENTIALS.
THIS WOMAN VOTED FOR SANTOS AND
WAS DRAWN TO HIS POSITIONS ON
PUSHING BACK ON COVID-19
MEASURES IN SCHOOL.
[CROWD CHANTING]
>> BUT THE NASSAU COUNTY MOM
SHOWED UP AT A RALLY THIS WEEK
ORGANIZED BY STATE DEMOCRATS TO
CALL ON HIM TO RESIGN.
>> THE WHOLE PERSONA THAT HE
CREATED AND THE ABILITY TO
DECEIVE US IS SO TROUBLING.
THIS MAN SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED
TO BE IN OFFICE, AND WE ALL
KNOW IT.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE NO JOKE.
>> AMONG THE SALUTE A
FABRICATIONS --
>> SENT ALSO MISREPRESENTED
HIMSELF AS JEWISH AND CLAIMED
HIS GRANDPARENTS WERE HOLOCAUST
FIBERS, SOMETHING GENEALOGY SAY
THERE IS NO RECORD OF.
>> HE'S A MAKE BELIEVE PERSON,
HE'S A PERSON THAT IS REALLY
NOT THERE.
>> HERE IS A JEWISH COMMUNITY
LEADER WHO MET SANTOS TWICE AND
THOUGHT HE WAS THE KIND OF
FRESH FACE THAT THE DISTRICT
NEEDED, BUT NOW --
>> GIVEN WHAT YOU KNOW NOW, IF
THE ELECTION WAS TOMORROW, AND
YOU HAD TO DO IT ALL AGAIN,
WOULD YOU VOTE FOR GEORGE
SANTOS?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT, I COULD NOT
IN GOOD CONSCIENCE.
ONCE SOMEONE LIES TO ME, I
COULD NEVER TRUST THAT
INDIVIDUAL AGAIN.
THE HOLOCAUST IS SOMETHING THAT
TOUCHES THE HEART OF EVERY JEW,
AND SOMEONE THAT WOULD USE THAT
AS A TALKING POINT, AS A VOTE
GETTER, I THINK IS WRONG.
>> BUT SOME SAY HE SHOULD HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO FURTHER
EXPLAIN HIMSELF.
>> THE MAN DESERVES HIS SAY,
AND HE HAS THE ANSWER TO A LOT
OF PERSONAL QUESTIONS ABOUT WHY
WE'RE AT THE SITUATION.
THE BOTTOM LINE, AT THE END OF
THE DAY, HE HAS TO OWN UP TO
EVERYTHING.
>> HE HAS NOT DONE ANYTHING
WRONG, AS FAR AS LEGALITY WISE.
HE ADMITTED HE LIED, AND MOST
CHRISTIAN PEOPLE BELIEVE IN
FORGIVENESS, MAYBE NOT FORGET
BUT MOVE ON.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> AND DISAPPOINTED VOTERS ARE
NOT THE ONLY CONCERN FOR
SANTOS.
FEDERAL AND LOCAL PROSECUTORS,
NOW INVESTIGATING THE INCOMING
CONGRESSMAN, WHO IS SET TO BE
SWORN IN NEXT WEEK.
>> SO THE RESPONSE IS SOMEWHAT
VARIED, EVEN THAT JEWISH
COMMUNITY LEADER THAT WE SPOKE
TO, EVEN THOUGH HE SAID HE
WOULD NOT VOTE FOR SANTOS AGAIN,
IF HE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY, HE
WAS NOT OUTRIGHT CALLING ON HIM
TO RESIGN.
ONE THING SEEMS TO BE PRETTY
CONSISTENT THOUGH IN OYSTER BAY,
IN GREAT NECK, THESE
COMMUNITIES, A VERY WEALTHY
DISTRICT, BUT THESE COMMUNITIES
NOT ALWAYS IN THE NATIONAL
SPOTLIGHT.
I THINK THERE IS CONSISTENT
DISAPPOINTMENT THAT NOW IT IS
BECAUSE OF THIS CONGRESSMAN
ELECT THAT HAS PULLED SO MANY
LIES THAT THEY ARE RECEIVING
THIS TYPE OF ATTENTION I SHOULD
NOT KNOW THAT THE DISTRICT ALSO
INCLUDES PARTS OF QUEENS AS
WELL.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU SO MUCH,
EVA MCKEND.
JOINING ME NOW IS CONGRESSMAN
TORRES.
WE JUST HEARD SOME FROM
CONGRESSMAN-ELECT SENT TO SOON
TO BE CONSTITUENTS.
WHAT DID YOU HEAR THERE --
NOW THAT WE KNOW THAT THEY WERE
LIED TO ON SO MANY DIFFERENT
FRONTS?
>> GEORGE SANTOS SHOULD RESIGN.
AS FAR AS I AM CONCERNED, HE IS
A SOCIOPATH WHO DEFRAUDED THE
VOTERS OF NEW YORK STATE AND
MR. SANTA'S NOT ONLY LIES, BUT
HE LIES ABOUT HIS LIES.
HE CLAIMS HE NEVER LIED ABOUT
HIS WORK EXPERIENCE AND ONLY
IMPOSED HIS RESUME.
HE CLAIMED THAT HE NEVER SAID
HE WAS JEWISH AND THAT HE WAS
ONLY TWO --
AND ALL OF THESE LIES WILL BE
LAUGHABLE OR THE STAKES NOT SO
SERIOUS, THE FACT THAT THIS
DARLINGTON, THE SNAKE OIL
SALESMAN IS ABOUT TO BECOME A
UNITED STATES CONGRESSMAN, AND
HE'S ABOUT TO HAVE ACCESS TO
SENSITIVE INFORMATION AFFECTING
MATTERS OF NATIONAL SECURITY.
WHEN YOU'RE A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS, YOU RECEIVE SECURITY
CLEARANCE BY VIRTUE OF THE
POSITION YOU HOLD AND I HAVE NO
CONFIDENCE THAT A REPUBLICAN
-CONTROLLED HOUSE WILL PROTECT
THE PUBLIC FOR THE FUTURE
FRAUDULENCE OF GEORGE SANTOS.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE DONORS IN
THIS CASE?
I SPOKE WITH SEVERAL CAMPAIGN
DONORS AND PEOPLE WHO ATTENDED
HIS FUND-RAISERS TODAY.
THEY COME MONDAY FELT
DISAPPOINTED, THEY FELT
BETRAYED FOLLOWING THE
ALLEGATIONS OF FRAUD AND
MISSTEP OR SCINTILLATION
AGAINST THE UP --
SHOULD THEY GET THEIR MONEY
BACK?
>> GEORGE SANTOS SHOULD RESIGN,
AND HE SHOULD RETURN EVERY
SINGLE CONTRIBUTION, AND EVEN
WORSE THAN HIS LIE IS POSSIBLE
LAWBREAKING, AS LATE AS MAY
2020, HE REPORTED EARNING A
SALARY OF $55,000 A YEAR.
THEN IN 2021 AND 2022 HERE IN
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 3.5 AND 11
POINT $5 MILLION.
THAT'S AN ASTRONOMICAL GROWTH
AND IS WHAT, THAT HE NEVER
FULLY EXPLAINED, THAT HE LENT
HIS OWN CAMPAIGN OVER $700, 000,
AND HE CLAIMS THE SOURCE OF THE
MONEY IS THE ORGANIZATION WHICH
HE OWNS, BUT THIS ORGANIZATION
IS SHROUDED IN SECRECY, HAS NO
PUBLIC WEBSITE, HE'S NEVER
REVEALED ANY OF HIS CLIENTS ON
HIS FEDERAL DISCLOSURE, AS
REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW AND SO
ALL OF THESE ARE SIGNS AND
GROUNDS FOR SUSPICION AND
INVESTIGATION.
>> WE DO KNOW THAT
INVESTIGATORS ARE LOOKING INTO
THIS ON THE FEDERAL AND LOCAL
LEVEL BUT AS YOU KNOW, HE HAS
MAINTAINED HIS INNOCENCE SAYING
HE IS NEVER BROKEN ANY LAWS --
YOU PLAN TO INTRODUCE A BILL
THAT REQUIRES CANDIDATES TO
DISCLOSE UNDER OATH THEIR
EMPLOYMENT, EDUCATIONAL AND
MILITARY HISTORY, IT WILL BE
CALLED STOP ANOTHER
NON-TRUTHFUL OFFICE SEEKER ACT
WHICH, PUT TOGETHER, AT SANTOS.
HOW DO YOU THINK YOUR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES IN THE
HOUSE SHOULD HANDLE SANTOS ONCE
HE IS SWORN IN NEXT WEEK?
>> THE REPUBLICANS SHOULD CALL
ON HIM TO RESIGN, AND HE
CERTAINLY SHOULD BE RELEGATED
TO THE MARGIN.
HE SHOULD NOT BE APPOINTED TO
COMMITTEES THAT HAVE ACCESS TO
SENSITIVE INFORMATION, BUT THE
REPUBLICANS BEAR RESPONSIBILITY
FOR GEORGE SANTOS.
THE GOP CONFERENCE CHAIR AND
MEMBER OF THE NEW YORK
DELEGATIONS ENDORSED AND RAISED
$100,000 FOR SANTOS.
REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP KNEW THAT
HE WAS A FRAUD AND SAID AND DID
NOTHING, SO AS FAR AS I AM
CONCERNED, THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
IS COMPLICIT IN THE FRAUD THAT
GEORGE SANTOS PERPETRATED
AGAINST THE PEOPLE OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> AND WE SHOULD NOTE, WE
REACHED OUT TO THAT OFFICE AND
DID NOT HEAR BACK.
A DONOR TOM MADE THAT STEFANIK
DID INTRODUCE THE DONOR WITH
SANTOS, BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE ACT
SPOKE TO TODAY, WHAT ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR OPPOSITION
RESEARCH?
>> LOOK, THERE WAS A FAILURE
ACROSS THE BOARD, ON THE PART
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE
MEDIA, BUT ULTIMATELY, IT'S AN
INDICTMENT AT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
HE'S A REPUBLICAN NOMINEE, AND
NO ONE IN REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP
HAS SAID ANYTHING ABOUT HIM,
EVEN AS A REPUBLICAN THE A
OPENED A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
INTO M